in this video we'll talk about spina
bifida spina bifida is one type of
neural tube closure defect so what is
neural tube in order to understand that
we have to understand the 101 of neural
development
so neural development is roughly
happening around the day 21 to 28 and in
this case you can see the embryo from a
top view
so in this case the flat sheet of
ectoderm would fold into a tube-like
structure which would eventually give
rise to the brain and spinal cord of the
embryo so you can see the cranial end
and the chordal end are demarked here
eventually
there would be folding of this neural
tube and the cranial and the chordal end
would create a neuropore a small
structure which need to be folded to
close the tube
eventually these structures are closed
completely
by day 28 this event is done so let me
summarize by looking at a top view and a
cross section view you can see how these
flat sheet of ectodermal cells are
defined as neuro ectoderm and they fold
into a form of tube and this neural tube
is the precursor for our internal
nervous system including the brain and
the spinal cord now neural tube defect
occurs when the cranial or the caudal in
fail to close if the cranial in failed
to close it leads to a situation known
as anencephaly with the entire brain is
kind of missing and when the caudal in
fail to close properly it leads to the
situation known as spina bifida so moral
of the story spina bifida is a
neurodevelopmental disorder which is
resulted due to a failure in caudal end
of neural tube closure
now there are different subtypes of
spina bifida
so this is how a normal end of the
spinal cord look like here you can see
the vertebral bodies the spinal cord
here and the spinal processes as shown
in this case so there are three types of
spina bifida one is spina bifida okay
Ulta occult in Latin means hidden so in
this case nothing really happens it's
kind of like the most mild form of spina
bifida
some uh some cases it has been seen that
one or more vertebrae of the spinal
columns would be malformed or in extreme
cases they could be missing
so this is the most uh
kind of like benign form of spina bifida
and there are some amount of hair
development on the back nothing more
than that
then the next type of spina bifida is
meningocele in meningocele a portion of
the meninges protrudes out at the back
and it forms as pouch-like structure
which is filled with cerebrospinal food
fluid
and in this case no nerves are actually
protruding out of the layer of the skin
and it may have minor symptoms but most
of the cases the major
conditions of spina bifida is basically
myeloma meningocele in this case
the spinal nerve as well as the meninges
protrudes out and form a pouch-like
structure sometimes the external skin
could be completely missing that means
it is open and exposed to the external
surroundings
that is why this is sometimes known as
open spina bifida in meningo mine in
meningo mine malacyl which is difficult
to pronounce the spinal cord and the
meninges protrudes from the child's back
many cases there are no skin on the back
bones of the spine do not completely
form in this case and this has resulted
in incomplete spinal canal and the
protrusion of meninges and the spinal
nerves spinal nerves are now exposed so
they are more prone to damage and there
is also risk of infection from the
external world this can lead to many
symptoms most commonly loss of sensation
and paralysis in this area
now let's talk about the risk factors of
spina bifida one of the biggest risk
factor is malnutrition
so nutritional status especially the
folic acid deficiency then exposure to
environmental toxicant obesity and
diabetes are the potential risk factors
and above all there are some genetic
predisposition among some ethnic groups
which make them more vulnerable to
develop neural tube defects
now a pregnant woman should take always
vitamin B9 folic acid and iron before
even thinking of pregnancy because
everything is happening with the the
nervous system is developing within the
first month and in that case
before even she knows that she is
pregnant the neural tube closure is done
and in that case if you don't have
sufficient amount of vitamin B9 most
likely it is going to create a neural
tube defect
so now it is advisable that every woman
who is thinking of conceiving until 12
week of gestation should take high level
of folic acid
now cases of neural tube defect shows a
very high incidence rate in the third
world countries
because in the third world countries
there are malnutrition and problems
associated with diet and they have very
low level of vitamin B9
now diagnosis can be done using
ultrasonography also there are
biomarkers such as Alpha phyto protein
which can be detected from the amniotic
fluid or even in the blood high level of
acetylcholinesterase is another
biomarker
treatment option include involves like
prenatal surgery which is dangerous but
surgically closing the defective neural
tube is one of the option some cases
doctors also prefer to do a postnatal
surgery and surgically closing the
neural tube is the only option which can
minimize the risk of meningitis and
other infections in the later later age
so I hope this was useful if you like
this video give it a good thumbs up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
see you in next video